all right so this is an extra video just
talking about the spoilers how can we
not yeah you know it's one of those
things were you know we don't want give
it away for people that haven't seen it
but at the same time you know it's
something spoilers you got to talk about
because they really do make a big impact
on this movie and whether or not you
like it or you don't like it so this is
total spoilers this is giving away some
I haven't seen the movie yet
don't bother watching this cuz we're
just gonna go through every single
spoiler and you're just gonna be very
angry okay so the biggest one the big
twist now we're saying it's gonna piss
everybody off is the Mandarin the Ben
Kingsley character that they're building
up is gonna be the didn't piss me off
it's gonna be the great big badass in
this movie he's on the poster he's got
the shades he's there he's saying you
know you will die and stuff like that is
just an actor he's just a pawn if he's
acting like he's more yeah Tony's Tony
Stark calls him Ringo at one point and I
thought that was brilliant yeah it does
sound like Ringo and they make him the
most pathetic bitch and it's funny it's
very funny it's hilarious and the funny
thing is like Kingsley is so many some
people are just like I just how could
you take a steaming dump on that
character I did not see that coming I
was like really cuz from the get-go I
was like what accent is that where is he
from get anything on this Terra's video
isn't it yeah I'm just like I really was
like they have to explain this at some
point because this does not make any
sense and I thought the payoff in the
sense that they explained why this looks
so bizarre was great I thought it was
hilarious and on top of that with the
commentary I think they often have it's
not that these bombings are planned it's
that this device they've created that
supposed to fix limbs but is unstable is
blowing some brain always so they need
yeah but so they haven't it they need a
reason so they make up a terrorist now
that's really clever and really funny
and I think it's a great commentary on
media and the use of the meat yeah now
the problem is and this is what I was
saying in the review is that the initial
twist is great it's hilarious you know
like okay so he's a total fake which
means there's another much more evil
villain somewhere now where's the payoff
nothing yeah I see nearly nothing guys
freaking Pierce is the payoff guys the
overbite guy
is never a payoff anybody who ever any
screenwriter out there listen to me if
you think your payoffs gonna be guide no
don't do it it's a trap but oh my god it
it just it goes nowhere so that's what I
was saying it's like you're you're being
shown a football game and then all of a
sudden they turn the football game off
and you're like what the hell you're
like no we're gonna show you the best
hockey game you've ever seen it's gonna
be crazy and then they show you Disney
on ICE's like that twist was so great I
was like oh this is gonna be nuts and
then this is like oh and so our backup
villain is Guy Pearce and oh you know in
the the other thing is a lot of people
are going nuts cuz they're just like
well mandarins just such a cool
character and I just he's he's so
amazing and to see what they did it's
just a big fu to the you know Marvel
fans and this and that hey if that's
your stance I totally respect that I get
why you would be angry if I were
attached to Mandarin I would be like
what the hell here's the thing and I
explained this on my facebook I not I
never as a kid reading Iron Man in the
80s thought Mandarin was an interesting
villain I never got it do you do you
know anything about Mandarin not a thing
okay so I have to go way back I have not
touched in Iron Man comics since 1993 so
as far back as as far as I can remember
if I'm remembering this Norris wanted to
be a gangster yeah I always wanted to be
gangsters as far back as I can remember
Mandarin grew up in pre-revolutionary
communist you know pre communist China
and his parents yeah his parents were
wealthy or something and then the
revolution happens I think his in one
storyline his sister dies or something
point being he goes out and finds this
crashed alien ship or something or alien
technology from obviously yeah from some
planet like Klaatu Barada nikto is that
I can't remember the name but and it's
like alien Dragon technology
and there's alien dragons I actually
sounds awesome it was something like if
I'm remembering right I'm sure and we'll
get a thousand Commons and like no it
wasn't quite bad but I'm trying to
remember something from like 20 years
ago in my life okay and then he
basically gets these ten rings of power
yes so he has these ten rings and each
one does something you know different
and that's kind of cool but in the end
you have somebody that is like half
fu-manchu's half wizard running on magic
but it's alien technology so he's Haley
and Matt yeah so he's like half tech
scientists half like wizard because it's
practically magic it was not one of Stan
okay greatest ideas okay just from that
description that sounds awesome but not
an Iron Man it was ridiculous I mean
even as a kid I just was like I didn't
get it and I still I was like this is
just it was just weird so I mean for me
the fact that they took something that
would in my opinion would not have
worked in a movie at least not in an
Ironman without the Ironman they said
yeah where they were they've kept this
pretty much magic and stuff out of it
and we did introduce aliens through I
was gonna say we did I only do the
aliens in the Avengers but I can't even
describe why I feel that would work
better than Mandarin would but there's
something about mandarins backstory that
just struck me as very desperate what I
lust and respect Stanley so much but you
know not every idea can be brilliant and
that was one of the more in my opinion
it felt kind of a little desperate I
mean like ten rings of powerful Manchu
weird I mean he looked kind of like he
looked like Shang Tsung if I remember
right from Mortal Kombat he had like a
long robe in some of the comics and so
it for me I would never be able to take
that seriously in an Iron Man movie to
begin with and I get the impression that
the screenwriter and the director or
whatever yeah and I saw I feel that
their answer around that was to go well
we'll just make him ridiculous because
you can't take this guy seriously to
begin with so that didn't bother me now
if your point of view is Mandarin is an
awesome character I would totally take
that seriously and screw you Rama hey
fine by me I'm like I would be pissed I
would be totally pissed it is did
reading a totally new
carrot yeah it is creating a new carrot
it's not even creating a new character
it's basically dumping on the carrot
yeah but it just didn't bother me
because I was never attached to Mandarin
to begin with it's a problem with most
of our man's villains as most of Iron
Man's villains in the comics were not
really all that interesting and as we
said this shows because in the end
Obadiah Stane ended up being the best
villain we've had in the trilogy and
that's it's not hardly as they love ya
that set the bar pretty low so um and
the other thing I think was sort of a
big issue again just going back to you
know stark just being to serve this
emotional idiot now instead of getting
smarter and smarter is that you know at
first he says I still don't know exactly
what the pant acts are from but he
claims it's from wanting to protect
Pepper Potts and throughout this movie
he constantly gets her in danger and
like half the time I say she has to get
the series about her so much for me that
the one that pissed me off the most was
ways it's like I'm gonna tell you where
my home address is and the first thing
that happens as he walks through the
door is peppers and has their suitcases
ready to leave and I'm like yeah if IRAs
girlfriend that's totally whatever like
somebody comes up to his door it's like
oh come on we're supposed to have
high-tech security I just threatened you
know terrorists and stuff it's like yeah
no that's legitimately stupid you moron
but bomb like he's trying to protect you
know Pepper Potts here and half the time
she has to save him she gets the Iron
Man suit on at the very end pretty much
what happens is that the big fake-out
that we were talking about is that she's
given this chemical this that keeps
blowing people up but it grows back
their limbs and stuff and I guess the
guy thinks he perfected him with her
maybe or something I don't know but a
second he injected her I already knew I
was like okay she is going to probably
end up saving the day somehow because
she has these superpowers and she's
gonna live no matter what so he's got
he's holding on to her is this great big
fire death at the bottom and you know he
either can't hold on or slips her since
she goes into the fire okay and again
just to show what a fucking idiot
emotional idiot this guy is he just sees
her fall goes huh Wow Baron epic climax
and he just walks off and fight like
he's not even that upset
and kinda for that reason I was just
like I'll be sure yeah so now it doesn't
fake out we're not good enough they
don't have the character commit to the
person that he cares the most about
apparently it's having these panet acts
over apparently is gon help when I bring
on the ultimate a panic attack I mean
what do you think I mean should he just
like wail or is it on the wave the way
she was used to begin with
they walked a very fine line of trying
to say no we're gonna do some girl power
thing here while at the same time being
like well we're just gonna do fanboy
like is this total fanservice like you
know they've they have her like
basically in a sports bra strapped up to
some sort of torture device through the
last third of the movie and I'm like you
know this is like I'm we can have your
cake and eat it too I'm just like
they're really just juggling this around
as if they just like well we don't want
to offend the horny boy demographic but
maybe we want to check to see this movie
so and that bother because there's one
scene the scene where she gets the he
throws the suit on her when the house is
under attack because he advertised where
their home address was while she's young
dumb ass she gets like 10 seconds in
that suit it's really cool and I'm like
she obviously doesn't know how to power
and I'm like well that's yeah a person
good laugh you know that made for some
good laughs I'm like well this is cool
I'm like maybe she'll be in the suit but
yeah I was like this is gonna be really
awesome and instead it's all of 10
seconds before it starts like alright
that's enough
oh and then basically like sucks the
suit back damn I was like that's it
okay I remember her just I remember
reading an interview on the web and
she's like yeah I get to wear the suit
and it's really cool and I was like oh
well that's gonna be awesome and then
when it was done it was like 10 seconds
she'd better be in this suit again by
the end of this you know I mean there's
so much larger is if she thought he was
dead because they get separated and she
learns how to use this and she has the
suit and she has the big revenge and he
also has the bigger event and she's
going out kicking ass in the suit while
he still does the exact same thing he
did before you know rather than just her
you know hide away which if he was so
concerned he would still try to be
making his way back to her to protect
her
and while we're talking about rewriting
Iron Man 3 you know what else would have
been awesome instead of guy Pierce the
answer to nothing the real villain
should have been Starks ex-girlfriend
yeah I'm like kind of is she kind of oh
yeah she basically shares she pulls a
Lando Calrissian she's like I'm kind of
the villain now but I've got second
thoughts and then like Guy Pearce shoots
her but I mean basically it would have
been so much cooler if she was the
puppet master if she were controlling
Guy Pearce and that basically what you
would have there would be a much more
interesting dynamic cuz Guy Pearce just
does the creepy like i'ma load myself
over Pepper Potts here and you're gonna
be my trophy I was like I've seen that
in a thousand action films would have
been way cooler it was the ex girl but
we loading lording herself but then we
might have Dark Knight Rises again and
remember where Bane is just a bitch the
whole time it is like yeah but there's a
huge difference guy Pierce is not Bane
okay no you know universe liked it it's
not in what it would have it wouldn't
have saved the whole movie but it's guy
it's not like we're gonna sit here and
be like oh that sucks they make Guy
Pearce a bitch yeah yeah it's just like
oh so Guy Pearce is just is you know Guy
Pearce as he always is but but the last
thing I'll say before I finish off here
is that what I'm seeing more and more is
that the more more emotionally stupid
stark gets the more and more responsible
Pepper Potts gets because even though
she does have to be saved a lot of time
she also fights back a lot of times she
delivers the finishing moves at the end
and it's pretty badass now it is it's a
- shoehorned into me like it's like nope
I'm saying why don't they take the you
know what she is learning and what she's
figuring out how she's putting stuff
together you know receiver box well I
mean it's whatever you doing with her
irons pots what are we doing with her
it's right accepted to where she's like
oh this is too hard
someone else you know that was bullshit
but in this is I want to remember that
again I remember nothing from to I think
that's why up and it's like you're not
going to be in the Avengers it's like
you yes I am and then the Avengers came
off he's like told you so
again just that Iron Man 2 but you know
here it's like whatever you're doing
with her in this movie with having her
kind of evolve and learn things and
stuff like and do that with Stark not
just the technical you know have him
actually do stuff Nancy martyr
emotionally and Freeman narrative
perspective what is the biggest problems
man the villains suck what is one of the
reasons that the villains suck no real
connection to Stark
none Obadiah Stane had the closest he
had worked with stark all those years he
was jealous of stark and the reason I
think the first he works as probably the
best villain is until he puts on the
damn suit which was stupid
he's known him for a while yeah the
first two-thirds of the movie is really
creepy because you know he's basically
just trying to kill stark the whole way
through you get that tension between the
two you know but Mickey Rourke what the
hell was it it's like my daddy worked on
some idea where your dad and I'm here
it's like hey you remember years ago
that person I propped up I think this is
every person like the exact same by the
way the other thing that bothers me is
going to that Iron Man 3 the villains
it's the exact same plot it's like you
kind of did something to me a while ago
and I'm pissed off and I'm coming back
10 years later okay you ever see like
those creepy kids at cons it goes up to
a celebrity it's like hey you want to go
out you all go out to get to do it yeah
yeah just meet me over there and then
the celebrity never shows up
that's your villain okay if the guy that
got really angry that you know it's
basically a credible I'm like it when I
saw them like really we're gonna go with
the Incredibles plot I loving girls and
I'm like that was a comedy I'm like you
know just some jilted fanboy like but
that's my point is there's no connection
now imagine if now you'd have to rewrite
this character but I wouldn't go exactly
the same way they deny Man 3 but knowing
Starks womanizing knowing how he's
trying to be in a stable relationship
would be nice an ex-girlfriend it would
have been so awesome if it was an
ex-girlfriend that has come back to
frickin haunt and like all of his past
sins come back
and once and want to take him out and
can you imagine the angst between the X
and Pepe and have your apology I know
you got you and like bitch I mean the
between the three of them I'm like that
would have been awesome but no we get
guy Pierce I think we have a script for
our I just sir I think it's too late I'm
open for some reason yeah I filled the
only other thing that's a spoiler is
what bothers me the one thing about the
Ben Kingsley twist that did bother me as
funny as I thought it was is the fact
that they went with the ten rings that
was the terrorist group in the first one
so it's just weird it doesn't seem to
have a connection with that group it's
kind of the League of Shadows again the
dark yeah it was just I thought that was
just really strange is like okay so
we're gonna bring the ten rings up again
I mean it's obvious when they wrote Iron
Man 1 they did not think the plot was
gonna go in the direction that 3 did but
by using the Tim rings again I was like
yeah this just seems kind of lazy to me
it's like and then in the end as though
it's all a big ruse and I'm like so what
connection did this 10 rings have to the
first 10 ring yeah it didn't even make a
connection to start and again this is
why ever you do like man they make a
connection and if you do like Mandarin
and I didn't but I get why if you do
like Mandarin why you'd be so pissed
because you saw the 10 rings an Iron Man
wanted if you've waited three films and
then this is your payoff so again didn't
bother me but I I understand why people
are pissed about it but when they asked
me I'm just like well it didn't bugged
me but I would understand if you really
wanted to see Mandarin and waited three
films because you would you'd be like
what the fuck
so that's our spoilers section and
hopefully we spoiled it for you
I think the screenwriters did that
already good boy all right take care
guys